all the kind of details that we can chew
over now with the shadow Chancellor
labors Rachel Reeves a very good morning
to you thanks for coming in so what did
you make of it
I think there's two key things that I
would have done differently and
approached differently uh yesterday the
first is around Fair taxes and you've
just set out some of the tax changes
yesterday but some of the things that
weren't in there for example the non-dom
tax status still exists if we close that
loophole that would bring people in to
pay tax if you make Britain your home
you should pay your taxes here it could
bring in more than three billion pounds
a year private Equity bosses their
income is not taxed at the same rate
that ordinary working people's income is
is taxed that's another loophole that
should have been closed yesterday and
instead of just coming time and time
again to the ordinary working man and
woman asking them to pay more in taxes I
would like to see more from those on the
broader shoulders that the second thing
that it was really frustrating not to
see yesterday was a real plan for
economic growth because ultimately that
is the way to lift living standards and
despite a lot of the Doom and Gloom I'm
really ambitious about our country's
future there are Industries where we
have real strengths from some of the
green industries of the future to Life
Sciences to data and fintech and there
wasn't a plan yesterday to really make
the most of our potential as a country
okay and I'll come on to latest plan in
a moment but but first you talk about
your concerns about this but there's a
lot here for you to like isn't there I
mean more higher earners could be paying
more more tax with those shifting income
tax thresholds poorer people largely
protected there's a rise in the living
wage working age benefits rising in line
with inflation there's a lot that labor
should like here isn't there
I didn't feel like that I must say I'm
really worried about what's going to
happen to people's living standards uh
next year from April big increases in
gas and electricity bills whilst the
windfalls of War being made by the
energy Giants are still not taxed to the
degree that they they should be in every
pound left on the table 10 percent
there's still those windfalls of of war
that we could be taxing more we should
not be having these investment
allowances uh which it just means that
there are some big energy companies that
aren't even paying any of this windfall
tax that's not right and and so we would
have done more on that front to
alleviate some of that pressure on the
ordinary working person who you know at
the moment you you get your income is
being eroded by double-digit inflation
and now it's going to be eroded further
by these range of stealth taxes that are
coming in and we know that bills are
going to go up further next year so I
understand that people feel really
anxious about what's happening at the
moment and when you see some of the you
know big companies in the very
wealthiest in society you know getting
off scot-free I I just don't think
that's right it's not the right
priorities well the chancellor insists
is that it's the better off that are
suffering the most here well not if
you're a non-dorm not if you're a
private Equity boss not if you're a
banker he would say but not but the
point it is that if you're a non-dom
you're not paying your taxes in Britain
so it doesn't matter whether the rate
kicks in at 125 Grand or 150 Grand
you're not paying it if you're a non-dom
that is the whole point and so we should
be closing those loopholes and again if
you're a private Equity boss you're not
paying income tax you say it's all a
capital gain uh and and that's taxed at
a lower rate so that's why we've got to
close some of these loopholes to make
our tax system uh fairer okay let's see
what labor would do shall we because the
chancellor is announced tax Rises now
and spending cuts for later two years
later when it's possible that labor
would be in power so would you stick to
those spending cards well first of all I
do recognize that because of the mess
that the Tories have made labor are not
going to be able to do everything that
we want to do as quickly as possible and
we've set a set of fiscal rules at an
incoming labor government would stick to
but again there are different choices
that could be made different choices
could have been made yesterday if the
government don't make those choices
those are the sorts of different choices
that we would be making around tax for
example at the next election I'd also
say this you know in the last year we've
had four budgets and four chancellors by
the next election we may have another
four budgets another eight budgets who
knows so I don't know the state of the
um of the fiscal position I'm going to
would you stick to those spending cuts
well I have said that we've got a set of
fiscal rules to balance day-to-day
spending to get debt down and we will
set out our our
particular our specific proposals at the
next election but I do recognize that
because of the mess they've made that
does impose constraints on an incoming
labor government but we would make
different choices uh in terms of tax to
alleviate some of that pressure on the
ordinary working person and also we were
put in plan our plans to grow the
economy because ultimately that is the
way okay living but I wanna I wanna I
know you can't talk absolute specifics I
want a general idea of what you're going
to do as far as the spending is
concerned if you do I mean do you want
more money spent on public services well
I've said for example example on this
non-dom tax you know that we would use
that money by closing that loophole to
invest in the NHS Workforce but how much
money would that rate 3.2 billion pounds
but that's not a huge amount when the
whole budget is 136 billion the
government aren't doing it and that is
the whole point we could use that to
double the number of people going to
medical training school I say that's a
massive big deal to increase the number
of nurse training places Midwife
training places District nurses those
are just some of the differences so even
if you've got a different a difficult
fiscal inheritance and we know that a
labor government will have that because
the mess notorious have made you can
still make different choices you can
prioritize different things and under
labor it would be ordinary working
people that were prioritized and
ensuring that our public services are
lifted off of their knees which is where
they are at the moment and asking those
with the broader shoulders to contribute
more if you do want to spend more on
public services
a lot of the ideas have already been
used by the chancellor haven't they that
labor has talked about in the past like
the windfall tax on energy companies
like higher taxes for higher earners I
mean you don't have many options left at
you to raise the money well I've set out
some of them private Equity uh VAT on
private school fees uh the non-dom tax
status a proper windfall tax so that
those windfalls of War are used to help
people who are really struggling with
higher bills and higher taxes under the
conservative governments those are some
of the different choices that we would
make now if the tourists don't make
those choices they're the choices that
we would make after the next election
with the labor government do you back
the fact that Jeremy Hunt has honored
the triple lock on pensions and that'll
see pensions rise in line with inflation
it is right that the chancellor
increased the pensions and Universal
Credit and disability benefits in line
with the rising cost of living I'm still
concerned about what happens next year
when energy bills go up to 3 000 pounds
on average for for people and how people
are going to cope with that
um but I am pleased that those choices
were made because that's caused a huge
amount of uncertainty and worry for some
of the most vulnerable people in our
society and yet are you concerned that
while pensioners are protected a lot of
workers haven't been are you comfortable
with that and if you're not what kind of
pay Rises do you want to see the public
sector get to to match anything like
what pensioners are getting well I want
to see inflation brought under control
and and that means bringing back
stability to our economy and our economy
has not had that stability with wild
volatility in in in guilt prices and
yields
we haven't got very much time but should
public sector workers get anything like
pensioners
settlements I'm not going to plot
numbers out of thin air but what we do
need is the health secretary and other
government ministers treating public
sector workers with respect getting down
and negotiating this is the first time
ever that nurses have gone on strike
this should be a badge of Shame for this
government they can still avert it if
they take those concerns of those who
work in our NHS heroes in our country if
they show them the respect and treat
them with the dignity that they deserve
okay Rachel Ruiz thanks very much for
coming in thank you